كنت زعيم الحزب الذي سيطر على ماليزيا
لعقود من الزمن الحقيقه
البعض في تلك الفتره اتهم حزبك او اتهمك
شخصيا بالاستبداد في التعامل مع المعارضين
ما مدى صحه هذا الكلام
ولا حيوان حسنا فزت بكل الانتخابات التي
خطها خلال شغلية منصب رئيس الوزراء في
الفتره الاولى ثم في الفتره الثانيه من
شغل منصب رئيس الوزراء فزت بالانتخابات
الاولى ثم خسرت الثانيه بعد ان تمت اطاحه
من الحكومه التي شكلتها احزاب المعارضه
لماذا اصريت دكتور مهاتير على تشكيل حزب
مؤخرا تشكيل حزب
الملويه هي المسيطره عليه لماذا لم تختر
حزبا متعدد الاعراق
كان ذلك بسبب ان الملاوي سكان ماليزيا
الاصليين اصبحوا فقراء جدا مقارنه
بالاعراق الاخرى لذلك كان يتعين ان يتم
تمثيلهم بحزب مالوي يمثل عرقيتهم فقط
ويهتموا ببرامجهم
الا يعتبر هذا التغير في سياستك
بشكل مختلف عن المرحله الاولى التي حكمت
فيها ماليزيا
لم يكن تغيير مني وانما لم يكن التحالف
المشكل من الاحزاب قويا بمثل ما كان عليه
خلال فتره حكم الاولى